now well hello gentlemen
gonna shove that phone so deep inside
you you're gonna have to do kegels
stance or it I've never done kegels but
I've heard things weird thing protect
innocent people and they say clubs for
years and no one seems to notice us I'm
pretty sure people notice us now I'm
going to upload this video so all your
friends can see we've enough to call a
[ __ ] an agent at CMM so the video wants
us to come for me to get home Wow there
they are I love everything about you
anyone handsome face don't see you know
to us it's an opportunity to make a
bigger difference than we can in Ohio
someone that we've been waiting for
Dyna girl that's really good dancer
destruction in her wake
she's unscathed by the police and their
gunfire this is
let's unite boring
you gotta trick me I'd love to help but
I really don't think I should for Los
Angeles its Electra woman and Dyna girl
um I'm here to you're Electra woman
sidekick Dyna girl right and not our
psychic if you're not willing to follow
my lead
then spinoff I need to get speci mm
offices off of Wilshire I need to get
there as fast as possible
I'm non uber driver get out of my car oh
my god how many black princes are there
in the city get us out of here so we can
suit up oh right here I said suit up not
soup up
Angeles York City just got a whole lot
safer Electra woman and Dyna girl have
arrived
that's okay that felt really good
next time in front of humans in front of
humans I've been biased but that was
cool
finally finally an update about electrum
and dyna-gro
and then I wanted to surprise you today
and tell you that the future length
version of elect woman and Dyna girl
will be available for your eyeballs and
brain to hopefully enjoy June 7 6 7 16
that's a nice combination of numbers
also side know us fans will be able to
watch an early screening of the digital
series on full screen but more info
about that later but right now it's
about 6 7 16 when the feature-length
version of Electra woman and Dyna girl
will be available for you really
exciting I you guys I think will really
like this I like it it's different from
anything that Hannah Hart and I have
ever done I think it turned out well
everyone else that's involved in this
project is amazing so 6 7 16 get ready
for the feature-length version of
electro men and Dyna girl go to Olli and
Annabelle comm and sign up so that you
get all of the information as it is made
public because I am awful at being a
messenger of information just like the
worst terrible you only say don't shoot
the messenger but maybe like sometimes
shoot this messenger so like a better
messenger can do a better job get
excited let's go in diner girl Congo
sign up I don't know my family our
orangish lip stain to match my orange
shirt I just imagined that all of you in
unison sang together separately that
don't impress me much but I think
electrum and diner girl will actually
kind of impress you look how
self-assured I am